- We are the paradoxical ape,
bipedal, naked, large brain, long the
master of fire, tools and language, but
still trying to understand ourselves.
Aware that death is inevitable, yet filled
with optimism. We grow up slowly. We hand
down knowledge. We empathize and deceive.
We shake the future from our shared
understanding of the past. Carta brings
together experts from diverse disciplines
to exchange insights on who we are and
how we got here. An exploration made
possible by the generosity of
humans like you.
- If you go to Nicaragua today, you
can see these deaf children
hanging out in their
school playground using
a rich natural sign language to
communicate, and 40 years
ago this language didn't exist. Forty
years ago, deaf children in Nicaragua,
children just like these kids,
didn't have the ability
to communicate effortlessly with
one another like they do.
So how did their language, how did
this language get into
the hands of these children? If we think
about that, if we really think where does
any language come from, where does the
language come from. Languages really
central to human nature. It's universal.
Not every community has writing or numbers
or using the wheel, but every community,
every human community has a language.
Language is not something that we've
discovered out there in the world.
Languages come from us. They're product of
humans connecting and interacting in a
social network generation after
generation. So to see where this language
came from, I'm going to take you on a
little journey and retrace the path of
Nicaraguan sign language up to the present
day. When these children arrived at school
five years ago, they were already about
1,200 deaf native users of Nicaraguan sign
language, and there were hundreds of kids
older than them using this language around
them, in their school. These children
learned it from interacting with them.
Now, if we want to know what those
hundreds of kids who were older than that
first, that current day generation of
children. What they looked like. We can
look at the kids who were teenagers at
that time when they entered. So this first
group here entered the school in the mid
1990s, and at that time there are about
800 signers of Nicaraguan sign language,
and two hundred of them were at the school
at any time. You know, you could
see that this is--
it's a fast, it's fluent. They can talk
about the non-hear now. This is a natural
human language that's used for what human
languages are used for. If we want to know
where they got their language from, we can
retrace the steps of the language further
back when these kids were four and five
years old, and ask who were the teenagers
then when they arrived at school. So we
can look at the people who were you know,
10 years older than them. When these
guys-- These are the cohort that arrived
in the 1980s. So when they arrived, they
were about 400 signers of Nicaraguan sign
language, again 200 at the school. You may
be able-- if you have an eye for it, you
may be able to see how as we're going
further and further back, the language is
a little bit more deliberate. The feedback
is a little more explicit and the signs
are bigger and more symmetrical, they are
more two handed signs. There are a lot of
differences like that in my, a lot of the
work I do is to try and quantify what
those differences are. But if you wanted
to know who they got their language from,
so if I continue this retracing of the
steps. When they arrived at the school,
the older people were these people who are
45 to 50 years old today. When these
people where four and five years old in
the 1970s, when they first came to the
school, there were no signers of
Nicaraguan sign language. This is where we
reach the end of our retracing.
Nobody taught these people to sign.
The teachers at the school used Spanish
which they couldn't hear so this is really
where NSL begins with these cohort of 50
pioneers. They took the gestures and
actions that they observed as a raw
materials and wove them into a new
language. So we have this incredible
opportunity to see how languages are born
and evolve, and the rule that language
learners play in that evolution. I'm going
to start with the language of this
earliest first cohort of signers and walk
forward to the present day and start with
the most fundamental pieces of the grammar
that every language has, the structure of
the simple statement. So arguments and
predicates. How do you show who's doing
what to whom? So in English for example,
we use word order to do this. If you take
a sentence like, "A man taps a woman."
And you change the order of the words,
"A woman taps a man." You change who's
doing the tapping and who gets tapped.
Now, other languages might stick
inflectional endings on the end of the
verbs or even on the nouns to show which
person is the tapper and which is the
tappee, and to figure this out my
colleagues and I used non-verbal materials
to list sentences that can compare these
different aspects of the sentence. So I'll
show you how different signers respond to
stimuli like this. So in event like this,
giving event or this tapping event. Here's
what the first cohort's signs is looked
like. They have a very strict noun-verb,
noun-verb word order. So to say that a
woman taps a man, you've got woman tap,
and then tapped. Here's what this looks
like when the first cohort signer signs it
So I want you to see how he produces
that noun-verb, noun-verb order for
signing who tapped, and the sign for woman
which is produced like this, and who is
tapped, the sign for man.
So he's going to sign these nouns, man and
woman, and in the neutral area, in front
of his chest. Know that there's this
movement in the verbs away from and toward
the body in a way they can reflect sort of
iconically the way that movement happens
in the world. But they're centered in the
signer's body. He keeps this body centered
and neutral. So here's what it looks like.
Woman, tap man, get tapped. Right? So this
is all very nice, clear and orderly, but
the interesting thing is that it wasn't
reproduced this way in the next second
cohort. So starting in about 1983 or 84,
the second wave of kids who're coming in
took this direction in which signs are
produced and started giving that job in
the grammar. What they did was start
modifying where they produce their signs
as a way of showing who did what to whom.
So in this example in the first panel, we
have the words see and pay produced in
this neutral area in front of the chest.
Then in the second panel you can see the
signs have been modified so the direction
is to the left. So if these signs were
together in one sentence produced by a
second cohort signer, it would mean that
that same person was both seen and
paid, right? So these inflections started
out with the verbs like this but soon
after in the mid 80s, you can also start
producing nouns in particular locations to
link them to verbs and more recently you
can even use it just a point to one
location or another to refer to the person
associated with that location. So now
you're using these locations and space not
to talk about where or something happened
but to show who's involved. So here's an
example where the second cohort signer
does, and you can see how these
developments really changed the basic
structure of the sentence, right? So, here
is the woman giving to the main event, and
you'll see we get the nouns now being
produced in particular locations that
correspond with the direction of movement
in the verbs to show you what the object
or recipient is. There are the steps
with the addition of
the spatial modification on the signs that
came in changes in the world or whatever.
So now the verbs move to the end of the
sentence. So you're going to see, first
she actually talks about-- remember those
three people in that scenes. So she starts
talking about the woman on the right just
looking straight ahead then she touches
her chest, that's a switch reference
device, then you'll see she does woman,
man, your nouns, and give, receive, your
verbs. Woman look and then self, woman,
man give receipt. Okay, if we move to the
third cohort, we're going to see the
introduction of the space, saw you. So you
use your points linking the verbs with the
doer and the done too. So this is an event
where a woman pushes another woman, woman
in a black shirt, and a woman in a green
shirt. So he's going to index the black
shirt to his left and woman in green to
the right. Then come the verbs, remember
now they're at the end, push, be pushed.
Finally you'll see this verb respect at
the end, and what I love about this
example, the respect sign here. Is that
even the respect isn't something that
moves from one person to another and know
who's telling. Here we're going to see the
space and the movement of the verb linking
it to the nouns. So you can say green
tells black, the black should show green
some respect and you do all that with one
word using the space. So black, green,
push, be pushed, respect. See? Okay, so we
can measure three structure in many ways,
and here's one. If you plot how frequently
points are used in that way that shows who
rather than where, you get this pattern.
So starting in the left with home signers
who are deaf people who were never exposed
to a sign language, and then the first,
second and third cohorts. You can that
they all use points to show where about
the same amount that something would stay
pretty stable. But this nominal use that's
used to show who, that's linking the noun
with the verbs. This use really increased
with the second and third cohorts of
signers. So the questions why this changed
and if children are so good at learning
language and someone has already developed
the perfectly good way to mark subjects
and objects. Why didn't the second cohort
just learn to sign it the same way that
the first cohort had been doing it. I
mean, it's one thing to gradually drop
whom from your English but this is a total
restructuring of the language here. So to
answer that question, I think we really
need to take seriously this idea of
language as an organism.
Language is an organism, so this isn't
just a metaphor when we say this is-- A
language is an abstract thing, it's
abstract but it's still real. It's a
bundle of structured material. It's self
replicating and we each live in that
symbiotic relationship with that language,
like the microbes in our gut. Like we
can't survive without it and it can't
survive without us. Language changes and
adapts to the humans that host it. So the
social network of people that learn it and
pass it on are the environment in which
language evolves.
Now, the different versions of Nicaraguan
sign languages that we see signed by
different aged cohorts today represents
this living record of the evolutionary
path of the language. So you know, the way
that I've been doing my work that I
described is you know, I look at the slice
today, right?
If we start with the 1970s in this figure
over to the left and you have the first
cohort coming in, and then in the 80s the
second cohort joins, and then the third
and fourth. We can look at today at the
differences between the cohorts, but we
can't forget that the action and moment of
change is over there, right? As we add
each new wave, and that's where the
language, that's when the language
reproduces, right? So the first cohort
builds the language as children in the
70s, and then they pass it on to this next
cohort in the 80s, and that second cohort
acquires it with sub-fidelity but they
don't copy it exactly. And so on in the
90s and today, and we know these changes
occurred when their children-- because the
path is uni-directional, right? So stuff
can get passed on to later cohorts, but
not the other way. It doesn't go back. So
things that adults initiate or learn, they
would be the same for everyone, and there
are things like that, that you see, that
are the same across all of the cohorts.
But these core ethics of the grammar, how
the sentence structured. How you do
agreement, how you show who's doing what
to whom. Those kinds of things, they're
changing just in that one direction, and
they don't get passed on back up. So this
change from one to two, then there's
where, that where, got re-interpreted as
who. So to take our questions about, "Why
change it?" We have to really think about
how languages replicate, right? What's the
mechanism that copies that code? The rules
and patterns of Nicaraguan sign language
and passes it on to the next generation of
NSL, right? Just because the organism
let's say 1980s NSL developed some cool
characteristic, doesn't mean you get to
pass it on for free. If we don't have a
really good understanding of the mechanism
of reproduction. We'll start to see
parallels between
development and evolution that don't
actually explain the nature of the change.
So most of us are more familiar with
Lamarck's second law here. This idea that
adaptations made by an organism in
response to its environment get inherited
by its offspring, right? So the sons of
the blacksmith must have bigger biceps, or
the daughter of the giraffe gets a
slightly longer neck than her mother
started with. But Lamarck also had this
first law that much as we developed from
simple cells to complex systems that all
organisms have a natural drive to
complexify. These are great ideas but they
don't work out, right? They don't work out
because now we know that reproductions
doesn't work that way. You don't just pass
them the useful stuff or the more complex
stuff, or the exercise parts. What we've
learned from Darwin, and since Darwin is
that we have to pay attention to
reproduction and selection processes,
right? Organisms send along everything,
they send out everything, not just the
useful stuff, but they do it with their
ability and noise. So the environment is
what's determining what will survive,
right? So now we really have
two evolutionary processes on really,
really different time scale. So we've got
human reproduction and selection on one
hand, and language reproduction and
selection on the other. It's not that one
recapitulates the other, it's each of them
is evolving in a shape by the processes of
reproduction and selection. In human
reproduction we pass on what kind of
patterns we can learn and it may be very
slowly and very long ago that more
effective and more powerful pattern
learning devices would prevail. But we all
came in to the world with brains that a
product of that process. On the other
hand, when language is reproduce, they
sent out you know, all this accumulated
symbols and patterns of combinations, but
it's a blurry and blended its signal,
right? It's just the output of someone's
own language, and it isn't copied
perfectly. In the process of selection,
it's not the useful stuff but the
learnable parts of the
language that survived.
So what we've got then is this
co-evolution of humans and their
languages. Each of them is serving as the
environment for the other, and each cannot
survive without the other. So, the thing
is though, that we don't set out to create
languages to grow languages, right? This
isn't done with an intention to make a
code. Humans grow languages because our
social connection is so critical, right?
When we pass a language from one
generation to the next, the goal isn't to
create something or to organize your
message. The goal is to connect, and the
drive is a social one that the idea is to
get your message into someone else's mind
and to understand what message someone
else is sending to your mind. In that
process of communicating back and forth
and actually forth and forth, that's how
we weave the fabric of language with
the machinery of our minds.
So thank you very much.